bonjour vincent pochon
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france ça fait un mois
quasiment jour pour jour que les
salariés du site chimie sont sont en
grève font des débrayages
qu'elle est l'avancée des négociations
avec avec la direction alors avec la
direction de sanofi en fait on est on
est face à un mur il n'y a pas deux il
ya aucune avancée on n'a aucun intérêt
en aucun interlocuteur de sanofi est
clairement ils sont en train de jouer le
pourrissement du mouvement quelles sont
les raisons précises exacte de votre
mobilisation aujourd'hui
alors nous sommes mobilisés parce que
nous avons nous sommes dans un processus
d'externalisation c'est à dire qu'en
fait à sanofi se sépare de tout d'une
partie de sa branche chimie est donc là
depuis le 1er octobre je ne m'appelle
plus sanofi mais je m'appelle euros
abbaye
alors clairement nous avons des
inquiétudes sur la viabilité de faire de
notre usine accueille des cinq autres
qui sont sortis avec nous
en fait nous sommes nous sommes sur des
mines qui sont assez vieillissante sur
lequel il ya besoin de de remettre à
neuf et des des équipements est
donc pour le moment sanofi
ne pourra pas à ses besoins et qui pour
nous sont essentiels pour assurer la
pérennité de notre site ça veut dire une
trame de licenciement aussi derrière
alors oui c'est à dire que en fait on
part avec une activité qui est déjà
réduite à l'heure actuelle et si demain
notre société et enfin euro un pays est
obligé de s'endetter pour remettre à
niveau ses usines oui ça pèsera sur ça
pèsera sur le potentiel de croissance et
et oui à terme on peut et on peut
imaginer des licenciements très bien les
salariés payent les les mauvais choix de
sanofi en matière de recherche notamment
on a vu le laboratoire qui a abandonné
son vaccin
rennes message et c'est cette politique
là que payent les salariés aujourd'hui
oui oui clairement fait un bon début on
n'est pas sur le nom n'est pas sur la
production de vaccins nouveaux ou dans
les îles dans nos usines fabriquant des
principes actifs en fait là on paye
l'abandon de la recherche dans la chimie
il ya plusieurs années de ça en fait
mapa de recherche en amont donc pas de
nouvelles molécules pour nos usines et
donc fatalement pas de débouchés comment
est-ce que vous expliquer cet abandon de
la recherche justement chez sanofi alors
qu'en fait c'est tout simple c'est que
sanofi dit
comment dire recherche la rentabilité
maximum donc pour pour enfin pour elle
des molécules dans la chimie qui sont
des molécules qui sont comment dire
qu'ils sont rentables en sarre est
rentable mais qui sont vieillissantes
qui ne dégagent pas forcément les mêmes
marges que les nouveaux produits issus
des biotechnologies
ça ne les intéresse pas donc ils ont
vocation à se désengager de ses
activités là pour se concentrer sur des
activités à forte valeur ajoutée et que
demandez vous concrètement aujourd'hui
en quelques mots alors il ya une des
revendications salariales c'est à dire
qu'une partie des salariés demandent une
une prime d
les salariés demandent une prime de
transfert nous ce qui nous intéresse
surtout c'est que à l'heure actuelle
nous avons des équipements qui sont
vétustes qu'il faut remettre en état
donc nous demandons ce que sanofi
provisionnent les fonds pour remédier
enfin remettre en état les usines et
surtout que des projets qui ont été
initiées par sanofi soit intégralement
pris en charge par sanofi nous avons des
nouvelles productions qui devrait
démarrer mais ça pèsera lourd sur les
finances de notre usine et nous estimons
que comme ça a été initiée sous sanofi
sûr d'être en charge de la z par sanofi
vous comptez mener des prochaines
actions dans les jours à venir alors oui
bien sûr nous restons nous restons
mobilisés
donc ça me surprendrait seulement tous
les jours devant lui zine et donc là
aujourd'hui nous allons participer à la
manifestation interprofessionnelle
armand et dans les jours qui viennent
nous allons continuer le continuer la
lutte
va s'inscrire dans ce mouvement national
aujourd'hui oui tout à fait oui lui ça
fait partie du livre ça fait vraiment
partie nardin tout il ya beaucoup de
raisons de quelque part il ya beaucoup
de raisons d'être en colère aujourd'hui
eh oui effectivement c'est nous sommes
en cas de la convergence des luttes
merci beaucoup vincent cauchon d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
délégué syndical sud chimie à sanofi